BE GUIDED BY THE TOPICS IN THE
MANNER THE PRESIDENT'S ADDRESS
TONIGHT.
>> Bret: DEIRDRE, THANK YOU.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT TONIGHT.
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS A COUNSELOR
TO THE PRESIDENT.
SHE JOINS ME RIGHT NOW.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
WE JUST HEARD DEIRDRE IN
NEW YORK TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, THE MARKETS TODAY.
FOR A PRESIDENT WHO TOUTS THE
MARKETS, WHEN YOU SEE A BIG HEAD
LIKE, IS IT A DANGEROUS THING TO
TOUT THE MARKETS AS MUCH AS HE
DOES?
>> THE PRESIDENT WILL RECAP THAT
IT'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS YEAR FOR
PROSPERITY AND SECURITY.
THERE IS NO MISTAKING THAT THE
DOW JONES STILL OVER 26,000 MADE
MANY RECORD HIGHS OWING IN LARGE
PART TO THE CENTERPIECE OF HIS
ECONOMIC AGENDA, HIS TAX CUT BUT
THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK GETTING
ONLINE.
NOT BEING SO BURDENSOME.
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT YOU'VE SEEN,
I THINK STRIKING AT THE HEART OF
OBAMACARE.
30 MILLION AMERICANS STILL DO
NOT HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
POST-OBAMACARE.
REPEALING THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
IS PART OF THE TAX PLAN.
ALL THAT IS LEADING TO UNTOLD
PENSION, EDUCATIONAL INVESTMENTS
PENSION, EDUCATIONAL INVESTMENT
INVESTMENTS.
HE WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
HIS HOUSE AND ECONOMIC RECORD
AND PROSPERITY THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE STOCK
MARKET.
THE OTHER ELEMENTS, CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE, MANUFACTURING
CONFIDENCE.
THE ON EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS YOU
AND JOHN ROBERTS WERE TALKING
FOR MARKETS TOOK A HIT TODAY WAS
BECAUSE OF HEALTH CARE.
COMMITTED TO FINDING A BETTER
WAY TO PROVIDE THE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AFFORDABLE, ACCESSIBLE
QUALITY HEALTH CARE.
THEY WERE LIED TO.
THEY COULDN'T KEEP THEIR PLAN OR
THEIR DOCTOR AND WE ARE STILL
CLEANING UP THAT MESS.
PREMIUMS, INSURERS FLING THE
EXCHANGES AND THE YOUNG AND
HEALTHY BEING TOO SMART TO BE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE MORE
AMERICANS HAVE ACCESS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED
POSITIVELY ABOUT ASSOCIATED
HEALTH PLANS SO THAT IF YOU ARE
ONE OF THOSE FOLKS WHO DO NOT
GET THEIR HEALTH COVERAGE LIKE
WE DO THROUGH OUR EMPLOYERS OR
LIKE OTHERS DO THROUGH THE
GOVERNMENT, THEN YOU CAN PULL
TOGETHER, SO YOU ARE SHARING THE
COST AND THE RISK.
THOSE WOULD BE SELF-EMPLOYED OR
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALSO TALKED
ABOUT COMPETITIVE RATES ACROSS
STATE LINES.
WHY CAN WE BUY OUR CAR INSURANCE
ACROSS STATE LINES ARE NOT
HEALTH INSURANCE?
ALSO POSSIBLY BLOCK GRANTING
MEDICAID TO THE STATES.
STAY ON ONE OF THE THINGS THE
PRESIDENT WILL TALK ABOUT IS THE
ECONOMY BUT ALSO REACHING ACROSS
PARTY LINES.
SAYING THIS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
AND THE ECONOMY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS HANDED AN
ALREADY HEALTHY ECONOMY BY HIS
INHERITED THE HEALTHY ECONOMY.
HERE ARE TWO WORDS WE WON'T HEAR
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAY TONIGHT
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
THANKS, OBAMA.
BECAUSE MUCH OF THE GROWTH IN
2017 WAS CREATED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S POLICIES.
>> Bret: THOUGHTS.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD SWEAR UNDER
OATH.
YOU DON'T HAVE A
SINGLE COMPANY OUT THERE SAYING
I AM MAKING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF REPATRIATED MONEY OR CAPITAL
INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE TRUMP TAX CUT.
THAT PASSED A MONTH AGO WHAT
THEY ARE DOING THAT WITH THEIR
EMPLOYERS IN THE LARGER
COMMUNITY INVESTMENTS.
HAVE THE ECONOMY IS EITHER
EXCELLENT OR GOOD.
THAT'S DOUBLE THAT IT WAS IN THE
FOUR PREVIOUS YEARS OF THE LAST
BIG FAN OF THE LAST PRESIDENT.
I'M SURE IF THEY WERE ABLE TO
SAY WE ARE BRINGING 20,000 U.S.
INVESTMENTS.
AFTER THEY WOULD'VE LOVED TO SET
THAT IN THE LAST DEMONSTRATION
BUT THEY COULDN'T DO IT.
WE HAD ANEMIC GROWTH RATE.
WE HADN'T CORPORATE TAX RATE OF
35%.
THIS PRESIDENT BROUGHT IT DOWN.
>> Bret: OFTEN TIMES STATE OF
PRESIDENT WANTS TO GET DONE.
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT THE DEFICIT
AND DEBT.
HERE IS CANDIDATE TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT THAT.
>>
>> WE OWE $18 TRILLION.
WE'RE GOING TO 21 TRILLION AND
24 TRILLION IS THE MAGIC NUMBER.
WE ARE THERE QUICKLY.
WE ARE GOING TO END UP BEING
ANOTHER GREECE AND MAYBE ANOTHER
DETROIT.
THAT'S WHERE OUR COUNTRY'S
GOING.
>> Bret: IF YOU LOOK AT THE
NATIONAL DEBT CLOCK, IT STANDS
AT 20.6 TRILLION.
LIGHT WHEN IT COMES DEFICIT
DEBT.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DEBT AND
IT'S EXPLODED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL ADMINISTRATIONS BUT WE
CAN ONLY LOOK AT THAT AND NOT
CONSIDER OUR CRUMBLING ROADS AND
BRIDGES.
UPWARDS OF 50,000 BRIDGES I'VE
READ IN SOME REPORTS ARE IN
DISREPAIR.
AIR TRAFFIC CONTROL SYSTEM
DESIGNED FOR A TIME WHEN WE HAD
100,000 PASSENGERS ANNUALLY.
SYSTEM.
WE WOULD THINK THIS IS A
NONPARTISAN ISSUE CRYING OUT FOR
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE HOPE IT IS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE HOPE IT I
IS.
THIS PRESIDENT IS COMMITTED TO
IT IS DONE IN OTHER COUNTRIES,
LIKE AUSTRALIA.
THEY GIVE PLENTY OF TIME FROM
PROJECT, YOU CAN BUT YOU DON'T
HAVE 20 YEARS.
HE CAN'T KEEP GETTING THESE
EXTENSIONS.
IT WILL COST MONEY AND IT WILL
IMPROVE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
THOSE OF US, ALL OF US TO
PAINT A BROAD PICTURE FOR
SOMEONE IS GOING TO TUNE IN
TONIGHT.
STATE OF THE UNIONS DON'T
SOMETIMES DRAW THE HUGE CROWD
BUT IT'S THE TIME WHEN ALL
GOVERNMENT COMES TOGETHER AND
YOU'RE IN THE SAME PLACE.
TO PAINT A PICTURE OF THE
SPEECH, WHAT WOULD IT BE.
>> PAY ATTENTION TO THE TONE AND
CONTENT.
YOU'LL FIND THEM INVITING,
CONCILIATORY UNIFYING, POSITIVE
AND UPLIFTING.
I HOPE PEOPLE ACROSS THE AISLE
TO SEE THAT AND FEEL IT.
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO GOD THAT
STEVE SCALISE WILL BE THERE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT 2017, ONE OF
THE DARKEST DAYS FOR ME WAS THE
DAY MR. SCALISE AND OTHERS WERE
SHOT.
THEY WERE MOMENTS AWAY FROM REAL
TRAGEDY.
I AM SO GRATEFUL TO GOD THAT HE
WILL BE THERE WITH OTHERS IN THE
HALL.
ALSO THE FIRST LADY'S GUESTS ARE
SPECIAL.
SHE HAS INVITED WONDERFUL,
POWERFUL STORIES, THE BEST OF
AMERICA.
SOME STORIES ARE TRAGIC AND SOME
WE OVERCOME AND COME TOGETHER IN